definitely easier for a woman to lose
virginie yeah yeah
by far
expand
I mean a guy asked it like a girl can
literally just raise her hand and you
know say who wants to do it with me and
uh a bunch of guys will flock her way
she kind of just doesn't show up right
guys actually have to put in a lot of
work to get laid in general but to go
from like kissless virgin to losing your
virginity and having a girl like you is
a bit of a process
I mean
do you think it's easier for women would
you say Abby yeah but I think also it
depends on your attractive level so do
you think that
um women losing their virginity depends
on their attractiveness
you get an ugly guy and an ugly woman
he's more likely to leave their
virginity it's hard it's because
obviously attract uh how attractive you
are is subjective but
I feel like typically attractive women
are obviously going to lose it really
easily but women who aren't your typical
so like I don't know if you're Maybe
overweight or not you're like what your
typical idea of good looking is then
obviously it's going to be harder which
might be on the same level as
um I don't know I I can't explain it
okay
um you find it you think men will find
it harder to lose a virginity well I
think men would find it hard oh women
yeah
um I think like I'm a 35 year old male
and I haven't thought about losing my
virginity since I was my teenage was it
hard for you no no like really
like it was just a natural process of
becoming an adult
um yeah like the whole concept to me is
quite foreign
because some guys say they like really
struggle with it um
um no not really not it's like like it
was always easy for you
to talk to women yeah some guys it's
like not natural to them which is
understandable yeah I mean I think it
can be intimidating it can be but like
no it wasn't for me I grew up with I
grew up in a quite a family with quite a
lot of female with a lot of female
influence and yeah I've never never ever
struggled to talk to women
what do you think
I would say it would be easier for women
to lose their virginity just because
women are probably more selective about
who they sleep with and men are less
because they just kind of want to get
laid but then if you're more selective
wouldn't it be harder generalized uh
well if you're more sexual yeah if
you're more selective wouldn't it be
harder well no because you can afford to
be selective when you have more options
I guess if that makes sense because more
and are more selective so men
like generalize see how you think women
have more options than men
um I think
are more willing to overlook
certain things in order to have sex
whereas women won't always do that so A
woman would be more selective in a lot
of Senses they have I guess more
um
I don't want to say standards it's not
about standards but just kind of what
they would want boundaries boundaries
yeah that's a good word for it 100 so
women have more boundaries
you said
yeah I would I would say that sorry I
would say that there is um there is a
need for women and people people
generally but women to have boundaries
um in order to not fall prey and trap to
um to
labels and titles that come with being
promiscuous I think that there's there's
um
there's a medal behind virginity that
that men kind of want to hold it's like
oh I've lost my virginity I you know I
want to tell everyone about it I don't
feel like there's that much of a medal
behind it for girls it's not like oh
I've let me put a pin in this because I
won I I think it's less of a um
there's not so much incentive for women
to lose their virginity whereas men I I
feel like there's there's more of a come
on you you should do this come on you
should do this come on you should do
this and there's a lot of um toxicity
behind that as well as like
ego that surrounds the type you know the
label virginity as well
so you think that it there was more you
think there's more pressure on women or
men to lose your virginity on men I
would say on men
you think it's on men yes so when you
were like at school when you were
younger like because I mean I remember
me being at school and there was there
was like you're still a virgin oh my God
you're still a virgin
oh my God what are you still doing a
virgin and I think a lot of the time
guys got to the point where they would
just lie about having lost their
virginity like so you didn't have the
same thing as a woman
no and I wouldn't say that um I think
it's really sad that anyone feels like
they have to lie about something in
order to be accepted within
um like peers and friend groups
um and I don't feel like there was that
sort of um
title that comes with losing your
virginity in a female I went to an all
girls school
um and I don't feel that there was any
any of that
um where I where I was at school so even
at all girls school there was no
pressure no I didn't did the girl's not
coming and say look I lost my virginity
yeah did they not do that yeah we did
that right okay but there was certainly
no pressure to do that there was no like
you know when are you gonna do it when
are you gonna do it it was a moment of
Pride as and when it happened
um but I don't think it was something
that I don't think it was a necessity
right like I feel like because I went to
Catholic school and I just feel like
people didn't really carry their way as
a girl like if you did cool if you
didn't yeah cool like yeah well you look
down upon in your school if you did lose
it
um no but it was like hot gossip right
okay like I went to a small Catholic
school and so like if you heard that
someone like because not a lot of people
really were I know the stereotypes of
Catholic schools but mine was more like
innocent I don't know what's the
stereotype I don't know what's there
I've never heard that like they always
say like Catholic schools are crazy and
I'm sure they are like some of them but
mine was like not like that I don't know
I mean in my experience Church girls
have probably been the freakiest girls
I've ever had sex with I know that it's
like uh but I would just say it was kind
of similar to like a small town where
like if something happens like
everyone's talking about it so you see
you like with virginity do you guys
think that
foreign
do you think that there's a pressure
the pressure to lose your virginity
creates a curiosity that just makes you
want to do it
um is that what happened at your school
uh no I mean I would say maybe more for
men but not as much for women
I would say okay do you think like The
Virginity nowadays is looked up on with
ridicule if you're a virgin
definitely guys yeah for a guy or girl
anyone no or both either or
I mean I would say for a guy yeah it's
kind of a little weird you call them in
cells but I would say for a girl if
she's 21 and she actually is a virgin I
think a lot of guys would probably not
believe her but as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible